thank you so much ruthvi that was pretty
amazing to
look through the presentation the
design of fine biotech after such a long
time
it's always kind of a nostalgic journey
for me
to look at everything and so i guess
we are ready to go and thank you so much
for this opportunity and providing me
this platform once again
to talk about this i know
i don't know what happened in the past
few years but this field has just got
its golden era you can see and
right now everybody every organization
every
department is talking about astrobiology
so before we move on to talk about
the fantastic and interesting aspects of
astrobiology and the research domains
that
is present let me introduce you to who
am i and
let's just give you a brief introduction
about me and my journey so far
so as ruth introduced me i am an
ex-research intern at
find biotech and let me tell you i was
the first
ever research intern of pine biotech
india
so just like you guys are doing i have
also gone through the courses and i
earned my certificates and stuff and
the mentors are so much friendly to me
even today you can see we are very much
i'm in touch with ilya
and he was very kind enough to pen down
some very
nice and kind words for me and so
that's the environment that's the
community we shared at fine and
even today i am really very much in
touch with
almost all the mentors and it's pretty
awesome but
let me talk about what happened after
that after i completed my finds
internship and then what so i had this
dream of coming to
this beautiful city of saint petersburg
which is also known as the venice of the
north
and get enrolled in a
university which is known as itmo
university
it was stands for information technology
mechatronics and optics
and that's the logo so i wanted to be a
part of this university and study
molecular biology and biotechnology
but didn't really want to do it
straightforward
so i looked for a scholarship
opportunity which is known as the open
door scholarship
which is provided by the russian
governments
and i hustled and got the result of
the scholarship exam and
scholarship project and i ranked fourth
globally
and also received 100 scholarship from
the government of russia and that led me
to a direct admission to my dream
university you can say
without any of the exam or
entrance examinations and yeah finally
i'm pursuing my master's completely for
free
so let's talk about my research
experience here
so that's the scammed laboratories which
stands for solutions of
chemistry advanced materials and
technologies that's a huge family you
can see
over here and currently i'm involved in
various projects
involving various such groups trying to
do something great in the field of
astrobiology
i would have loved to share the results
with you but you know they are
pretty much premature right now and not
really i'm authorized not really
authorized to share with them
right now but maybe in a future uh
cyamic session or maybe some other
sessions when they are
good to go good to be published i can
talk about them more but
finally i cannot forget space onova
the company where i am currently the
head at the department of astrobiology
and let me quickly share what's the
vision of space manova and why am i
devoting my time to space on over well
space nova is a
company which has the vision to
enable literally any space enthusiast to
become a space technologist in
any of the domain of space science they
want
and that's the kind of vision we all
share
and particularly being the head of the
department of astrobiology i
really want to understand the
perspectives of life
beyond the cosmic boundaries you know
let me give you an example
just like the nature of physics changed
once we took into consideration the
universal phenomenon like the dark
matter or the phenomenons of black hole
similarly it's my strong belief that
biology would also
see new heights will be explored in a
different way will
go beyond our expectations when we start
looking at
biology beyond the boundaries of earth
you know so that's a lot about me and
let's not talk about me much and let's
devote our attention and time to this
beautiful field called astrobiology
let's not drift away from today's topic
so
you know this is a night sky and i'm
pretty much sure
you once in your life might might have
looked up at the night sky and looked up
at these twinkling stars and glowing
planets and wondered if
you are the only one if earth is the
only place where life is possible
and you know with all the scientific
advancements that we have had over the
past
decades and so mars seems to be one
planet where life might be possible
right now or might have been possible in
the past we never
know that's our neighbor and so many
missions are planned to mars
but mars is not the only one we also
have other
candidates for example jupiter's moon
europa
maybe life exists on europa
but so far over the years after studying
and searching
so much the only planet which we have
discovered
to have life in this universe is a dear
pale blue dot or you're also known as a
blue marble
earth so the question which i get asked
almost
everywhere everybody asks me this this
question that
why do we really study astrobiology why
are we so interested
to search for life beyond earth what's
the need
well the short and crisp answer to that
question would be we are natural
explorers you know that's the
human nature that's in our gene that's
in our dna
to explore to know but why the universe
what's so special about that
well let's take for example this
particular comet
you know or maybe let's take an example
of any star for example the sun
everything in this universe each and
every object
is made up of the same star stuff
and what do i mean by the term star
stuff well
have a look at this this is a pretty
familiar picture to you all right this
is the periodic table of elements
but it's color coded pretty differently
and if you focus on suppose hydrogen the
first element is color coded in blue or
azure color and in the literature you
can find the term big bang fusion
so hydrogen originates when
it originated when there was a big bang
fusion let's take for example
carbon because every life form is made
up of carbon right that's the most
common element we know so carbon is
green and yellow
that shows exploding massive stars and
dying loma star
so if you look at oxygen if you look at
any other element
discovered so far we would see its
origin or its presence
in some of the other stellar event in
some or the other
cosmic phenomenon and therefore
we conclude that each and every object
in this universe is made up of
the same elements it's me whether it's
me
or it's you or it's a star or a black
hole everything is made up of the same
element and therefore we feel a strong
connection
between each of us and we want to
explore
them and know more about them so have we
ever tried to contact the
so-called life beyond earth well to be
honest yes
we did try to contact them that's known
as the
receiver message it was something
looking like this
i would explain what it means and it was
devised by the great scientist frank
drake in association with carl sagan
and it was short towards the globular
star cluster m13
with a huge data that's one six seven
nine bits of data
25 000 light years away now what does
this message
contain what's the content of this
particular message
so if you look at the first
if you look at the first level here the
whites it's the decimal system that we
have
the numbers zero to nine then comes the
purple one the purple one
is the elements which form our nucleic
acid that is hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen phosphorus coming to the
green part
this shows that different nucleotides
that we have
adenine guanine cytosine you know that
very well
then coming down it's a double helix
structure of our dna
this is a human structure that's pretty
easy to understand here the yellow
region shows the nine planets it was
nine back then but now unfortunately
pluto has been declared as a dwarf
planet
and finally the aerosol radio tower
which
shot this signal unfortunately this
receiver already observatory was taken
down a couple of years ago due to
malfunctioning
so we have tried to contact them the
so-called
them but have we ever received any reply
well to be honest we did but we really
don't know from where it came from
so we received a message from
the so-called sagittarius cluster or the
sagittarius constellation
which is pretty much visible in the
night sky and this is termed as the
famous
wow signal well what is it this is a
very sharp and strong radio signal
sharp and very prominent than usual so
you can see the usual
threshold it was way beyond that and the
scientist
jerry r a man was so impressed by this
particular
sp of this particular peak in the graph
that he wrote wow beside the paper and
since then
we call it the wow signal we really
don't know
whether it was an alien civilization
which
sent us this message but definitely it
was really
exciting and interesting to get so
talking about
life beyond earth do aliens really exist
that's
one of the most common question or most
common thought which comes to people's
mind
the answer is we don't know we have
never
ever detected any alien life form we
have never ever contacted them
but we do have some imagery of aliens
mostly inspired by the
movies you know like this one maybe they
are blue in color
uh owing to the copper rich blood maybe
just like
it's similarly seen in the octopus maybe
aliens are green
with three eyes like this toy alien from
the toy story movie
or maybe aliens would be like yoda and
many people would agree who knows maybe
alien might not be
so cute after all and they are these
ferocious beings with a hard exoskeleton
with a scorpion like tail
ready to pounce upon us and kill us the
moment they detect us
or maybe aliens possess those very
high supreme powers like the mad titan
panels from the avengers franchise
and maybe they are on a mission to
annihilate the 50 percent of earth's
population the answer is we don't know
and the possibilities are endless but
i want to draw your focus to this
particular creature if you know what's
the name of this creature you can head
down to the
chat section and write it down but
i'm pretty much sure you would agree
this is very peculiar not
something which we see in our locality
this
is known as the portuguese man of war
and
from here you would say that okay this
is a creature with a tent this
few ten tackles that's common but that's
not the case
these are not extend tackles but these
are very small microbial animals living
together in a colony in a symbiotic
relationship
giving rise to the entire structure and
that's pretty
awkward or pretty unusual similarly have
a look at this creature this looks like
a giant cockroach right with
disgustingly large amounts of feet
and this is something which we don't see
in our home crawling that would be
disgusting
this is known as the deep sea giant
isopod and again this creature is so
unique similarly have a look at this
creature
what is this well this is known as the
axolotl
and what's so special or unique about
axolotl well axolotl
the unique characteristic feature of
exotil is
they have reproductive properties or
they show sexual reproduction or
secondary sexual characteristics when
they are a larva
where when they are they are babies but
once they grow up once they become adult
they lose that property and that's known
as retrogressive metamorphosis
so you know there's so much about life
on earth itself that we
are not really aware of even after so
many years of research
so it begs us to ask the question what
is life do we really understand
life now if i ask you what are those
characteristic features which defines
life or which segregates living beings
from non-living beings
i am pretty much sure you would all
agree upon these particular points
for example responsiveness or
consciousness growth
definitely living organisms grow
metabolism and energy transformation
definitely that's key to survival and
obviously reproduction
without reproduction living beings are
as good as non-living things
that's some people's ideologies but you
know
i came across certain examples which
begged me the question i believe
let's take for example responsiveness
have a look at this picture
this particular thing which is moving
here is a nanoparticle
and it's responding to light to the
stimulus of light
so without any artificial help this is
showing responsiveness
on the contrary here's a plant what do
you think the will the plant
chase you and slap you if you break one
flower or a
or a leaf well a plant never does that
exceptions included
so you know even though they usually
don't show responses
they are living beings and therefore
responsiveness is pretty ambiguous
let's take for example growth you must
have seen these balls right these are
known as hydrogel balls they have the
property to absorb water and
grow in size and that's again growth
grow in growth in size
and volume so again it's growth is
pretty much
ambiguous let's talk about metabolism
and energy transformation
you would agree that this is a pretty
important
metabolic reaction that is respiration
the process of breaking down glucose
with the help of oxygen
releasing energy in the form of atp and
carbon dioxide and water as
byproducts but again on the down
picture you can see paper burning and
that's again the same reaction that's
carbohydrate
with the help of oxygen burning
releasing energy in the form of
light and heat giving out co2 and h2o as
byproduct
and again that's a challenging question
to ask finally
let's talk about reproduction well you
are all familiar with this particular
picture
and copying one particular file from one
device to another
gives rise to an independent file
which has its independent identity but
it resembles its parent
that's pretty much what reproduction is
so you know
if we talk about these characteristics
they lead to more confusion and more
unclarity and therefore maybe we should
really think about
defining life in a better way and one of
my friend
suggested in one of the previous
lectures that
if we combine all these characteristics
together
and you know combine them
and confine them in a particular vessel
which we call a cell maybe then we can
define
that this is something which we call as
living being maybe that's a correct
explanation
but we really need to understand life on
earth and then only we would be in a
position to understand life beyond earth
also the discovery of certain bacteria
species which
we known as extremophiles expanded the
knowledge of light expanded the range in
which we can
expect life so here's a quick activity
we can do think of three places where
life can never exist according to you
three very hostile regions
if you ask me well it would be volcanic
eruptions
high temperature thousands of degrees of
centigrade and
so many poisonous gases there's carbon
monoxide and stuff so
life should not exist here well
similarly in a very acidic lake ph
around one or even below that and life
should not
exist in a place which is so highly
acidic or maybe even alkaline
and the last place where according to me
i thought that light can never exist was
a vacuum of space
with so many harmful solar radiations
there's microgravity there's low
pressure
no oxygen so pretty hostile conditions
for life
right well again my beliefs got a death
blow when i came across certain species
of bacterium for example the
streptomyces thermophilic
which can easily survive in volcanic
eruptions
then there's acidothiobacillus
thyroxides which can also thrive in
highly acidic
ph and in space in the vacuum of space
completely exposed
was dinococcus radio uranus the
bacterium species which would survive
for
more than a year and that groundbreaking
experiment about the international space
station
completely changed the way we look at
live itself
talking about this particular experiment
about the international space station
it spanned between may 2015 and may 2018
it was named the tan popo mission and it
was designed by
jaxa the japanese aeronautical company
and you know in the japanese section of
the international space station which is
known as
kibo they exposed that kind of of course
radio endurance without any artificial
support
and they found that they could survive
pretty easily
for more than one year it's not that
there was no change noticed definitely
there was an ex
exo layer that was formed similar to
something like an endosponder stuff
which died and dried off but the
interior was surviving
and also scientists discovered that
dinofocus radio urants could survive so
well because of its
highly fast and efficient dna repair
mechanism
and that is pretty amazing to study
further because if we can devise
something and utilize that property
maybe we can realize the dream of long
duration space flies without getting
harmed
someday the tanpopo mission also had
another objective that was
capturing the dust flybys at the highest
level of the low earth orbit that is 400
kilometers from the earth's surface
so these are ultra low density silica
gels or aerosols
and they are very porous so they were
also exposed in the hope of capturing
maybe you know life forms microbes or
maybe
some sort of amino acids and now they
have been brought back to earth and
research is going on with the help of
pcr and so many other
mechanisms and who knows
fingers crossed and we might find
something interesting in the future
talking about extremophiles there was a
case study done in brazil
in the sao paulo and south africa and
you can see here in the list there were
so many different types of
extremophiles there that were found
there was hypothermophile thermophile
psychophiles
acetophiles and the list just goes on
and on you can
see that they can survive at
staggeringly high temperatures or maybe
very high radiation exposures can also
not affect them and these extremophiles
known as the polyextremophiles forms the
basis of astrobiological research
nowadays
and many people are interested in
studying their genome doing some
comparative genomics and stuff to
understand
them better where we can find these
extremophiles where here's some examples
this is a cave
in northeastern brazil then there's a
very dry region where we can find some
zero files
also in the antarctic regions we can
find underneath this
no regions we can find some
extremophiles
but um we might talk about them later
on some other day because really time is
cons
are constrained here and we have to
cover a lot so
with all these examples something which
is very clear is we
really don't know much about the life
forms on earth
and just like the saying goes that
charity begins at home
i believe that astrobiology also begins
on earth and is the best
place to do research and to know about
life so that we can be ready to identify
life somewhere beyond earth
now what is astrobiology well it's a
very multi-disciplinary subject very
multidisciplinary field of science which
incorporates under its umbrella a large
number of
fields of science but if i categorize
them into very
broad aspects there will be origin of
life studying
the ancient life forms in the prebiotic
atmospheres
their search for life beyond earth
definitely which i was talking about
and to do that we also need geology and
the study of the environment
and finally we have space health just
like
my fellow presenter dilora will be
presenting her research today
and that's on radiation that's a an
aspect of this particular domain of
astrobiology that
space health how to take care the health
of human beings
and shield them from the cosmic homes
one of the other aspect of astrobiology
is a study of microgravity you know
microgravity conditions open so many new
dimensions to our understanding
completely
you must have seen such pictures of
astronauts floating around
in microgravity conditions but very
interesting things also happen
under microgravity conditions for
example have a look at this water
droplet
you would never see a perfectly round
water droplet on earth and that's
because
of gravity 9.8 meter per second square
the acceleration due to gravity but when
somebody is in the microgravity
conditions
the gravity ceases to exist or at least
ceases to dominate and then forces like
surface tension can take over and
similar things also happens with all the
fluids in our body
be it blood or lymph and they start
flowing
upwards against the gravity and that
poses a lot of challenges
to whoever does a space travel so
it's really important to study all those
phenomena and all those
characteristics although space flights
are so interesting many people dream of
becoming an astronaut there are a lot of
challenges faced by them
to list a few well definitely
microgravity is a big challenge which
they have to cope
up with and adjust radiation is a big
problem
and again the lara has taken the first
step to analyze
those and their effects similarly
there's low oxygen and pressure that
leads to stress
and when somebody is stressed when the
body is stressed so many
different mechanisms go on and it can be
noticed i will be talking about them
in just a while there's extremely
fluctuating temperatures as well
and a big problem to space flights is
definitely bone and muscle density loss
that's a reason why astronauts
need to exercise at least four hours
daily but that's not enough as well
that's a huge amount of osteoporosis
which is detected in those astronauts
and we need to do something to
counterfeit that and to enable these
space missions to be more
smooth we're talking about the research
which can be done under this
microgravity condition
which is a very very interesting aspect
and domain
one thing which pretty much coincides
with fine biotech's
ideologies and antibiotics domain is a
genomic response to study the
differential gene expressions
and similar something was done in
association with nasa
the astronauts whole blood transcriptome
was analyzed before
they left earth and after they returned
after their mission
and surprisingly it was found that 234
related genes were differentially
regulated some were upregulated
somewhere down regulated some completely
stopped
their expression and that's such a big
challenge you would agree because
as many as 234 stress related genes
going per circle in a human body
would definitely lead to certain
physiological
uh phenomenon and characteristic leading
to certain diseases
and that's pretty much an area where we
need to focus and do more research
talking about diseases in space well you
must have heard about cancer right
cancer is such a big challenge to
anybody who travels
to space but it's not so sorrowful
and not so depressing news after all
because
fighting cancer from space is a very new
domain
let me brief you what happened in this
particular research
these cancer cell lines were cultured on
earth under stimulated microgravity and
also under real microgravity about the
international space station
and it was noticed then once
microgravity kicks in
these cell lines lose their potential to
get
adhered to the surface of the flows and
they start floating
and revolving and once they do so they
form multicellular spheroids
and these multicellular spheroids lose
their property of
getting attached to one another and that
leads to the loss of cell signal fungus
signaling and the property of cell
signaling and you know
that completely blocks the process of
metastasis
you guys who are studying cancer would
definitely know that metastasis
is an important stage of cancer
where it just becomes worst from worse
and you know this study already gave
that breakthrough that metastasis stops
when
microgravity kicks in and that would be
something very interesting to study
about and to know more to understand
the cell signaling processes well so
that we can devise something we can
understand something which would lead to
our
successful treatment of cancer in the
future
you must be remembering about the
example of bone density and muscle
density loss that i was talking about
a recent experiment what they did was in
a recent experiment was they genetically
engineered certain mice
and they knocked down the expression of
myostatin and actin
active in a coding gene and they found
that after
these mice which lack the these
particular
coding genes they become very much
sturdier their muscle and their bones
grow at a tremendously high rate that
cell signaling processing is completely
shut down so there's no limitation and
therefore the muscle density and bone
density loss is brought to
a very low a very
rock bottom minimal you can say so that
is another area another interesting
domain to look into to study
more so that we can understand how this
is happening and if we can replicate
them
in humans and maybe who knows in the
future just like these mighty mice we
would send mighty astronauts
onto the space station and even to mars
who would not suffer from the problem of
bone and muscle density loss there was
another experiment which
took this in association with merck and
nasa and this is a monoclonal antibody
known as k
through them that's again a cancer
that's a
treatment for cancer and what the
scientists saw was they could form
pretty much homogeneously and uniformly
under microgravity conditions which they
could not do
in the control sample on earth because
of gravity you can see such a chaotic
picture here but here it's all well
organized and homogeneous
that led to the better characterization
of these monoclonal antibodies which are
highly efficient
highly selective and targeting is almost
100 percent
so again you as you can see this
research open new domain
into this sort of small molecule drug
and
biologics ex research and stuff
finally let's talk about the recent
launch from spacex which took place on
june 3rd
and they sent two passengers along with
them that was the tardigrades or the
water bears and baby squids
the purpose of sending tardicals to
space was to analyze how
they are so rated how they are not
degraded by
microgravity conditions or harmful
cosmic
radiations and to study that what are
the genomic processes what's the
what's happening at the genomic level
that's giving them such
a great strength the purpose of sending
baby squids well baby squids are the
model organisms for studying symbiotic
relationships
and that's the sole purpose to
understand those symbolic relationships
which they
do once they go to space and that can
lead new horizons you know we
human beings are also in a symbolic
relationship with so many microbes
talking about our gut microbiome
and it's pretty much important to
understand the relationship between
those symbiosis and how it
microgravity can alter or affect them
so it's pretty much good to say that
space is a new lab
and talking about where the lab is
located well definitely the
international space station is one of
them
we are also coming up with axiom which
is going to be the world's first
commercial
space station russia is also going to
launch their own space station by the
year 2025
and good news for my indian fellows
india is also going to launch their own
space station and all of this space
station will have dedicated microgravity
research going
on board them now finally let me quickly
talk about the carrier opportunities
because that was one of the agendas and
let me tell that at the very beginning
it doesn't matter from which background
you belong you can still be an
astrobiologist
you necessarily don't need to be no
don't need to be
a biologist to become an astrobiologist
you can be an archaeologist and study
the
history of earth when the dinosaurs were
extinct when the oldest microbial fossil
was found
the formation of earth and also so and
you know
you can be a biologist just like me and
most of you are biologists
study the cell the cell organelles study
the nucleus the cellular process is
going
inside the central dogma of life and
study
the nucleotides their chemistries and
how they
interact maybe you could be a
microbiologist and study
tardigrades and their phenomena you can
also be a geologist studying the
formation of
studying these asteroids well these
asteroids are very interesting you know
because they are like those grandmothers
who know a lot about
our past asteroid bennu is one of them
and
it holds the secrets of the formation of
the universe itself
and therefore the osiris-rex mission was
planned and
now osiris-rex mission is bringing the
samples from the new to earth
and who knows what we are going to find
pretty much exciting
so as a geologist your purpose would be
to study the rocks the
history of earth and to analyze life's
evolution
you can also be an astrophysicist this
is the perseverance rover and its
partner ingenuity
which was a key rover sent to mars for
doing astrobiological researches
it landed on the jazeera crater but why
the jezebel crater because
the jesuit crater is the best evidence
of
a liquid ocean on mars you can clearly
find the delta the tributaries
carbonates and stuff that's a pretty
good hint that jazeera crater was a lake
or a water body
and if it was a water body then
definitely life could be a possibility
in those particular
areas so in a nutshell you can be
anybody a physicist chemist
biotechnologist food technologist
architect engineer you can belong to any
background
and still become an astrobiologist the
only thing that you need to do
is believe in yourself just take that
first step believe that you can be an
astrobiologist you can contribute in
this particular field
and you're good to go one interesting
observation was that i
told that you can be a food technologist
or a foodie and still contribute tester
biology
well that's pretty awkward but that's
the truth here you can see
an expert in food technology here you
can see people hired
what they are known as tasters and their
sole purpose
is to taste the food analyze them and
decide what's the best food to be sent
to space for the astronauts
so being foodie is no longer cliche you
can definitely
earn respect suitable jobs if you are a
foodie
so finally answering the big question
how to become an astrobiologist how can
i become what's a career path that i
should follow
so this is the carrier path which is
suggested by nas
and you can definitely follow this path
to become an astrobiologist right now
learn about astrobiology attend the
podcast
read books on a degree in any of the
field that you like
you can do your graduate work you can
build a community just like we are doing
right now finance drinks based on nova
is doing that's community building
learning together and then you earn your
phd and finally
you look for funding opportunities
become a postdoctoral fellow somewhere
and then you start doing your own
research in the field of astrobiology
and that's how
you can get a glorious career in
astrobiology that's what
nasa suggests and talking about where
you can know
more about these journeys well
definitely check out nasa astrobiology
program
as scan astrobiologist various
astrobiologists come and share their
life's experience
in those shows and that's an eye-opener
for anybody who wants to
be an astrobiologist in the future so
that's all i had for this presentation
today i
do hope that i did not take much time
here's the last invitation for anybody
who wants to be
a part of space anova's community of
global space enthusiasts you can join
our discord server
and let us together stay tuned and
create a space ecosystem
where limit actually turns to infinity
well thank you so much for your patient
audience guys
it was really amazing for me to talk to
you and i am pretty much open for
answering your question feel free to ask
any question that you might have
and thank you so much for this
opportunity